what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host down Saucon very pumped to
be talking about the global sham onic
resurgence we have Rackers m and i all
segments joining us on the show what's
up guys hey good to be here
pleasure Alan back for how are you guys
are getting into the high numbers of
rounds I think this is for for AK this
is to for Niles where the mines keep
going out evolve and grow and then they
come back and share their experiences
Rach Niles have been out doing the
second episode of shamans of the global
village if you haven't seen the first
episode yet of shamans of global village
pause this go and watch it you can find
the link in the bio below to the first
episode pause this watch it and then
your life will make more sense the
context you know some context for what
we're going to be talking about which is
their second episode in the series
they're both co-creators of Sean's of
the global village which is a
documentary series exploring indigenous
medicines and the global shamanic
resurgence alright so um we can probably
do a little bit of context here we've
done so many shows together now
exploring spirituality the nature of
reality why we're here
and most recently our show has taken a
turn where we've now been exploring what
is happening in modernity and how many
of the principles of indigeneity around
the interconnectedness with each other
and with our environment our are lacking
in modernity and we've been talking
about that so much on the show about how
to
how to architect the social fabric
that's more prosperous especially with
some of those principles and so you guys
in the sense are going and capturing
some of these principles in some of the
most beautiful styles of documentary
series that I've that I've seen it's
really well artistically put together so
give us a little bit of context
regarding you know you two deciding to
come together for this creation ship
around shamans of the global village and
and the first episode give me give us a
little taste of it and then also we'll
get into the second one yeah creation
ship good word well I'll just initially
say that the show is basically the union
of our skill sets and kind of brings up
that best aspects of both of our skill
sets together you know it's kind of the
pinnacle of what we've done so far in
terms of an artistic piece that we're
very proud of the pilot episode was made
in 2016 we finished in 50 well we have
it in 2015
yes so I will just initially setup by
saying that typically a show is done by
the entire season being completed with
you know some level of proper budgets
this show is very independently made so
it's being done on a little bit of a
different way right where we've made a
pilot episode and then essentially I
kind of joke that hopefully we'll get to
every other episode more often than the
band tool makes an album but each
episode is a very big undertaking it's
kind of like making a documentary
feature and documentary features can
take years to make so here we are about
four years later having nearly completed
a second episode because of other life
requirements right so we've made
essentially what is the equivalent of
two feature documentary films on the
subject which we'll get into but here
comes the second one numerous years
later that the gears are turning slowly
but they are constantly turning and so
we'll get into that but do you want to
give some insight as to the first
episode of the background well I guess
I'll say it is an ambitious project I
think it's so much a bit like the 12
tasks of Hercules
it's like it's like some thing yeah and
I think it's a necessary thing because
as you're talking about modernity and
indigenous sort of perspective and
wisdom there is an imbalance in the
world that is out of touch with the
wisdom of the ancestors out of touch
with the wisdom of the indigenous people
out of touch with the planet and
ourselves and a show like this is
visioned to communicate the essence of
what these cultures are doing mediated
through plant medicines which come from
nature and are all over the planet and
these people are the caretakers for and
their caretakers not just for the
medicines but for the energy behind it
the relationship with the planet how
that mediates their communities and so
as I've been noting with episode 2 and
we've envisaged you know a series it's
probably 12 or 13 episodes which looks
at entheogenic or psychedelic compounds
which have been used traditionally all
over the world like many of them in
Mexico South America potentially Egypt
Iran Australia you know Siberia there's
there's all around the world planet
secretes these substances and there's
been relationships with them so it is a
big undertaking and an ambitious one and
I think it may take the rest of our
lives buddy at this right but I think
it's what it's doing because yeah
there's a lot of university within each
episode and you're seeing a lot of
different capacities of the role of the
healer or bishop or the shaman as well
and conceptually the way that the first
episode is structured in the plan for
future episodes is that each episode
focuses on a specific medicine plant or
animal and a specific practitioner who
works with it so we have kind of a
primary primary people we focus on per
episode and then there's sometimes these
secondary or tertiary guests with RAK
hosting but yes I mean shamanism is as
old as the hills and it's not just about
the medicines but it's about the
practitioner as the legacy you know and
much to do with environmental issues the
rights of indigenous peoples which we
know are very much always under the boot
of modern structures of Commerce and
imperialism and just the day to day
ways that the West operates for all of
the East and West in terms of
commodifying everything in the natural
world so this show has is a very full
spectrum show and we learn a lot by
doing it you know each episode is such a
huge pilgrimage for us that it's a
massive undertaking
each one is not only such a huge
creative project but it's such a life
learning journey as we do each episode
because we don't necessarily know how
the next one is going to happen we just
let it kind of synchronistically come
about with our other roles and
responsibilities through life so it's
like when are we going to get back a
record episode how are we gonna make it
happen how we're going to implement it
there's things that are always when
you're doing things independently how
are you going to have the financial
resources to do it or how are you going
to bring this into manifestation and we
find that we very much are led as each
episode comes into fruition and we've
you know hopefully will continue to yes
get a full series under our belt
sometimes before we croak yeah it's it's
really cool also artistically seeing
your forces come together to manifest
this like you said that you guys have
these key components that went pieced
together can make sean's of the global
village exactly the work of art that it
is I want to ask you both about this
this is we're gonna get into much of
like the ethos and the philosophy of
what we're talking about as we explore
these conversations so I don't want to
just ask a question about that
specifically because it's gonna come up
naturally but a question that I think
could interest so many of us around this
is how do you pick because there's so
many indigenous cultures around the
planet that have these sacred
ritualistic relationships with plants
and for awakening for healing for all
these different methods and you have on
your website you have a your like your
series roadmap you know you have you to
listen to all these countries all these
how did you pick those and you know the
first one was on the Sonoran Desert toad
right so how do you guys pick yeah that
one how did you pick peyote for the
second
yeah I guess the shorthand is that they
pick off in this sense that well to
backtrack a bit you know I first went
down to the jungles and worked with
ayahuasca in 2006 and in making a
writing a book about that experience and
about what the West was engaging with I
started to say that there was a pattern
that had been happening generationally
where the West had been re encountering
plant medicines and as medicines which
were care taken by indigenous peoples
and so there was a understanding that
you know through research that all these
different cultures around the world
originally had an entheogen ik or a
psychoactive sacrament and that's not
just indigenous cultures per se it also
goes back to the Greeks with the rights
of a lucious
and the kaki on their their medicine if
the Romans who had something the
judeo-christian ik religions had you
know acacia sand cannabis and the
anointed the you know themselves there's
there's there's no war on drugs in
prehistory right and so in choosing
which shows to do in this culture in the
modern Western paradigm we have been
constrained by legalities and we have
upheld those legalities right so number
one it's like are these indigenous
medicines utilized in a country where
they're legal and then number two it
comes down to well what is the medicine
of that area like for instance we've
been we've done two episodes now in
Mexico because culturally and
geographically Mexico down through
Central and South America is where the
repository a lot of a lot of
psychoactive medicines still exist so
there you know is the bull file various
toad which was episode one there's
psilocybin magic mushrooms in Mexico
there's salvia divinorum Mexico and this
peyote in Mexico indigenous to Mexico
there's also other sacraments but we
didn't want to get top-heavy with Mexico
the finding countries where they were
legal and then it comes down to in my
almost 15 years of being in
the Western shamanic culture having
worked with ayahuasca and the poor
photoed in the last few years and
encountered at conferences and online
and different people it's getting the
pulse of the global shamanic community
and in the global shamanic community
contains both indigenous people and
Westerners or you know first worlders
who are engaging with the medicines but
it is a collective whole and so within
that and this is maybe drilling down a
bit much but there's a lot of a
diversity a lot of good practice and
some bad practice and so sometimes it's
been a matter of reputations and of
working with people that I II personally
know or that their reputations seem to
be integral enough to want to represent
them and sometimes you find out things
or things happen after you've worked
with a practitioner so we recognize that
there is a duty of care to our viewers
in who we present and for instance the
the lead of episode 1 dr. Octavia
Reddick who is was and is very
controversial in the photog community
has become even more controversial when
people have died and we acknowledge that
people have died are in his care or lack
of duty of care regardless of his
intentions and that there is a delicate
balance in doing this work and
representing it as media so we aim to
document as documentarians we're not
advising people do these substances
we're not advising that they do have
these experiences with the people that
we show we're trying to show warts and
all the character of the person that
works with these medicines and when I
first went to Peru almost 15 years ago I
was told within the first few days there
were three things essentially which cure
and arrows or as we call them shamans
have almost every single one of them
issues with money with power and with
women right and so it is hard in Iquitos
to find someone in Peru one of the
ayahuasca hotspots to find someone that
doesn't have a shadow or a scholar
in their closet and so we do that and we
do look at people and things will either
that we don't know or things will come
up in their practices and sometimes
there is there's two sides of the story
sometimes says there's things that
happen with the people that shamans work
with especially with Westerners and
there's lots of issues sometimes around
a culture clash or different cultural
expectations or also around the role of
you know this ego guru worship of the
shaman in Western culture because of the
absence or lack of that archetype in our
culture and the need for healing but
there's often a response to put these
people on a pedestal so we don't want to
do that we want to show Watson all we
want to show the pressures of the role
the duties of the role you know what
that is like and yet I will say that if
as this continues and we do this work
reputations change so people should
really look into the current status of
the people they work with as we have
tried to do and also there's an element
of documentarian ism where it's focused
on the person to tell a story about the
medicine and there's so much to learn
culturally there's so much to learn
about these spaces of spirituality that
I would hope that the final product no
matter what the reputation of the
practitioner is still worthy as a
document documentary yeah
honesty transparency is key and it's
true it's like indigenous cultures have
problems just like mo guaranteed he does
you know there's nothing perfect about
anybody just like every individual has
their pros and cons and nobody's here
that's not perfect that's perfect
everybody's got things they're working
on so it is interesting to see when we
visit a tribe which in the second
episode for example we're with the we're
going to a specific part of Mexico where
they do an annual pilgrimage and just to
be there is a special process but you
see the way they live and how they have
massive struggles and you know how
they're very poor and they have things
that they do well and other things that
they do
not well in the sense of how modern
culture operates some of the things that
we do are great and other things we need
to learn a lot from indigenous tribal
communities and vice versa so that's a
huge learning experience every step of
the way and highlighting that the
shamanic experience specifically what is
essentially the psychedelic experience
in a shamanic container is very
important for part of getting to have
some glimpse or insights into gnosis of
experience and knowing that spiritual
processes spirituality is your life so a
shamanic experience can help give you is
a tool for the larger spiritual process
of your life so just like RAC said not
putting these experiences up on a
pedestal but knowing that they are there
as a way to help us find balance with
nature and Gaia and divinity and cosmos
and reunite with the greater ecology of
things because one thing that indigenous
tribes have typically done well and that
we've seen during the processes of
visiting them is that they have a much
more beautiful balance and harmony with
nature and how they live and we know
that much of Western society today and
modernity is on a very unsustainable
path in a lot of ways so these are all
good things to highlight and each each
episode is a huge learning experience to
say the least and it's always good to
highlight that nothing is perfect and we
are always trying to make a piece of
cinema that is as educational as
possible as transparent as possible and
hopefully as entertaining as possible as
well yeah yeah oh yeah it's mmm it's
quite interesting that these pick you
and come through you but also discussing
these grand challenges of trying to take
all the beauty of the relationship of of
different indigenous cultures with
nature and with each other and figure
out how to best share that with the
world so that modernity itself can
awaken more to the beauty of that and
how to integrate it within itself
meanwhile the these these these issues
and
anthropologists and archeologists have
for the longest time been trying to
figure out how to not be extractive but
be symbiotic in the in the relationships
and and this is a very difficult thing
when colonialism is pushing in on on on
capitalizing on on extracting resources
from these lands rather than treating
them like the define things that they
are the legs they've been treated and
then also the commodification of this we
actually did a recent conversation with
the American Anthropological Association
is annual meeting with someone that's
doing fashion anthropology and this is a
very wild statement and I'll get back to
the main stream thought here but the
idea is that by working with different
indigenous cultures around the world in
the way that they communicate sacredness
and divinity of spirituality through
through fashion through their clothing
through their sacred objects these types
of things and then by in a sense
allowing a little bit of the economic
machinery into that so that they can
share the sacred myths with more people
around the world can catalyze the
awakening more and that in itself is a
very strange statement because it's
allowing the economic machinery in and
to try and spread the memes of what the
sacredness is through like yeah through
fashion and anthropology I don't that's
it that's just a statement that I
thought was realistic
yeah no you know okay it's it's a
complicated it's a complicated
discussion because of many reasons like
essentially indigenous people are to a
large degree broken or traumatized by
the first world you know by the new
world by the people that are essentially
almost like their ancestors in some
sense you know there's a there's a South
American prophecy called the eagle and
the Condor and essentially it says after
500 years
of colonial conquest by the Spanish the
conquistadors that you know the country
will come to a reunification of the
eagle and the Condor representing North
American South America and the mind and
the heart but you've got to remember
that all across the world the old world
was raped and pillaged and plundered and
slaughtered yeah on mass right so what
is the mental driver of Western culture
that is so damaged and so hurt that it
goes out into the world and does repeats
the victim mentality right it's been
traumatized itself and this dichotomy
between old world and new left and right
we're seeing in the world everywhere at
the moment I hope it's a precursor to a
grand reunification right Weiss because
I mean these loaded terms we're all
indigenous to Planet Earth yes right and
the labels we give in the separation we
give are just that that is labels so the
indigenous people in their situation
that the majority have found themselves
even in the first world countries
decimated and put onto reservations and
have held on to the sliver of their
spirituality you know in their practices
where they can and in larger countries
where they're still in nature in the
jungles and in the environments where
they are they may be impoverished and
surrounded by you know the capitalist
roll-out but they still have some
connection to the land and you've got to
remember that to the indigenous people
what we think of as spirituality it
sounds like a hashtag it sounds like a
buzz word it's like let's get all
spiritual and [ __ ] you know uh ayahuasca
it's trendy well this and that it's like
it's not necessarily even about the
plant the plant is a interface for a
relationship with the land and spirit
and spirit is what sustains you it's not
if you're just indigenous spirit is
something which we all have we're like
spiritual beings having a human
experience the
we've forgotten so we're just as damaged
as the indigenous people that our
ancestors have decimated and this is a
process of species trauma I think we're
all getting through and I mean
essentially I don't know if it's the
soul problem or the main driver but
capitalism is based on this idea of
capital which is based on the idea of
land which is based on ownership and
possession and money if you look at the
original etymology of all the
linguistics in English of money the
riches come from the soil it all goes
back to Egypt right that banks are you
know the devices on the side of the
thing which would alternate the the
water flow the levies they would put on
things in in tax terms are about water
it comes down to you can't eat money you
know it comes down to the of nature and
spirit is what the original currency is
and so spirituality isn't this fetish
thing that capitalism can absorb and yet
capitalism is a virus which devours
everything until you have a dead planet
so at the same time plant medicines are
being devoured by capitalism and they're
being diluted and for a large part I
would hope and most people I know in the
West who have felt the call of the
medicines to be caretakers to be
providers or to be facilitators or if
they even dare call themselves shamans
which is a loaded word in the global
shamanic community you know there's a
role and a responsibility and to a large
degree they have good intentions but
there's a huge responsibility and we are
seeing a dilution of the purity of
shamanism and of the purity of the
relationship of spirit and ceremony
itself in Western shamanism and so these
are really huge issues with no easy
answers and as the medicalization of
psychedelics juggernauts ahead and they
cage god for relieving the anxiety of a
capitalist culture which is battery farm
them into the
pression and and trying to kill them
there is a potential for the soma for
the masses where these things can be
absorbed by capitalism and yet there's
also a potential with capitalism and the
people within those structures are
receiving healing from these medicines
while they're being commodified so it's
a bit of a chase you know in both
directions and I trust that there is a
culmination to this process and the
things will all be well but it doesn't
mean that shit's not going to hit the
fan as we go through this process yeah
and it seems like the [ __ ] hitting the
fan is not this overnight zombie
apocalypse thing it's just a very you
know the the twilight of Empire is
obviously upon us so we see a slow
degradation back to some level of
authenticity and what human beings are
naturally designed to be like which is
somewhat indigenous right so people are
terrified of this you know peak oil post
you know assuming that global global
capitalism assumes and demands a planet
of infinite resources which is you know
you could argue materially we're on a
planet of very finite resources I think
mentally we have aspects to bring a lot
of things into manifestation that are
very powerful but it's it's it's very
obvious to a lot of people that things
must change and like you've talked about
on this show often times Alan we need
society up upgrades and new operating
systems and ways of doing things so many
of those things aren't just endless tech
thinking that it will save us it's just
more getting back to authentic ways of
being and living in the world and
indigenous peoples have constantly
struggled with this but it's it's
beautiful to see that at the same time
their spirit is often not broken right
like rock had said so it's very
beautiful to see that getting back to
ways that are more authentic which
definitely means that we might have to
chop wood and carry water a bit more in
the future
is it necessarily this awful thing right
it's like we can find a way of balancing
Commerce we you know with ways of being
decentralized and not as hierarchical
and it's not going to be the dynamic
where a shaman you know says that I
can't pay my bills with a feather in a
stone but there is ways to do to
continue forward and in ways that are
much more in balance in harmony with
nature right and I think a lot of these
things were at the point now
with what's going on environmentally and
ecologically that nature will force us
to do these things which seems scary it
seems overwhelming but oftentimes it'll
piss lead us to more authentic ways of
being right and it'll it's it's a slow
process so that's why it's good to to
have community and to have a not fear
you know fear is the mind killer as
Frank Herbert said so to realize that so
much of this is the larger spiritual
process which is spiritualities truth
spiritual and spiritualities in life so
just look to somebody's life to see how
they're doing in their spirituality and
just look out the Society is doing as a
whole in their spirituality which yes in
the modern world a lot of people's lives
are a mess so this society and the
culture is a mess but as each node on
the network does things to work on
bettering themselves and we can talk
about the whole reason and why that you
would do that but you can see how we'll
get back to some of these more authentic
ways of living more spiritually you know
harmony with nature I always bring it
back to nature the earth yes yes exactly
yeah exactly yes hmm
so the more that I embark on the depths
of this spiritual journey that that this
one is on that the more it feels as
though this is perfect that this reality
is perfect in the sense of it being a
perfect constant harmonization and flux
between the classical yin and Yan of
good and bad of light and dark of
whatever you want to call it and that
the extreme extremity of the younger
brother going out into metropolis and
having all the tinkering with innovation
but also the issues that are also
arising from that meanwhile the older
brother is still in the depth of
interconnectedness with nature and the
land in its most sacred ways that in
itself is that same perfect balance
right there and that when we say things
like it's out of balance
it's a we agree with that statement
because we're like that's why you're
doing the global shamanic resurgence
documenting this and trying to share it
with the world to catalyze the awakening
of this good side of this resurgence
meanwhile at the same time it's as
though there's on this on this evil side
that's constantly going up with the good
is that there's better and better
propagators of old archaic corrupt codes
that are trying to manipulate and an own
more in choke more the nature choke more
the spirit and that those two things
being in this ascension together pressed
up against one another
seems like why it's such a perfect
creation I'll get to another question
after that but how do you guys feel
about about that I like it yeah you know
it's this idea about sound bytes inand
again and like the hash tag thing it's
like spirituality isn't necessarily what
you think it is you know and good and
evil unnecessarily we think it is in
this polarity of the way we see the
world you know we're so stuck in duality
and we've forgotten the way right so
we're saying technology or nature
nature's a technology it's a vegetable
technology she secreted she created us a
biological technology
justice is the technology I mean all the
labels that are just illusionary things
that create fragmentation and separation
and so what is the value of shamanism
right why are we doing this show what is
the global shamanic resurgence what is a
shaman right we created that term the
West created that term it comes from
Siberian medicine work from the salmon
in their language and Western
anthropologist Merce a Eliot in his
classic book shamanism in the 1950s he
defines the role of the shaman as a
technician of ecstasy and again the
cultural drift of what the words means
ecstasy originally from the Greece ex
Tarsus means it's like communion with
God right it's that it's that powerful
that pure the ecstasy the joy of
discovering your spiritual nature is
that you're not separate you're not who
on what you thought you are you're an
emanation of the Godhead having a human
experience right yeah and these labels
and these words they're like maps
leading us back to truths which we've
forgotten and so the shaman is also in
potentially a Western interpretation a
healer a priest a traveler between the
worlds a mediator of the invisible
energies all around and he or she and
many cultures had female medicine women
and still do was a mediator of energy
because they understood that humans are
not separate right indigenous people
born in nature didn't live in a cubicle
shut off from air and sunlight most of
their lives of the DNA atrophied you
know it's like they were embedded within
an ecosystem with multiple life forms
multiple energies which extended out
into the the energetic or the astral and
they had to mediate those energies for
the health and survival of their
communities so number one the shaman was
in charge of the health of their
communities
and so as part of that the plant
medicines are really important but
there's also so many other roles often
shamans would be village elders or
chieftains or the personal politics that
all people have within them you know
that affects that we I'm just waiting
for someone to create an app talking
about technology that can visualize the
energetic ripples of when this person
says to that person and they get angry
and they go and see that that person and
pass it on and if you could visualize
you know there's visualizations they see
on YouTube of internet signals and like
the 5ge radiation and stuff and it's
like rainbows things if we could visual
visualize the emotional impact we have
on everyone around us even if we live in
our box and withdraw it's all connected
but the big picture is the West has
forgotten through its trauma through its
disconnection through its focalization
on you know this outcome on everything
that's out here it doesn't look back
here anymore it doesn't connect to the
feeling and so the idea of technologies
aren't good or bad right consciousness
is not good or bad it's what you do with
it so an egoic Western mind focused on
survival and out here and playing the
game of life seeing it as separate from
themselves seeing a way to climb who to
kill how to take out how to look after
me me me has created the planetary
emergency we now find ourselves in which
is still perfect and still going
according to some higher unification
plan Wow so the technologies you are
mentioning aren't necessarily wrong but
the intention unless as modern humans we
can deeply drink from the well of
remembrance and remember who we are what
we are why we're here then how can we go
out there and do anything that isn't
going to [ __ ] up everything mmm know
thyself
yeah and shamans you know through all
time were just the medicine people of
the village right and that's mentally
not necessarily physically right like we
have physical doctors of today but we
have a lot of
mental illness in our society and the
shamans could help with that so you talk
about societies that have lost their way
I mean we don't have any initiation into
adulthood in the modern world with this
traumatic experience where indigenous
cultures would typically have a young
sprout go off and do some pilgrimage and
have some experience whether or not
there was a sacrament involved or not
that initiated them into adulthood that
brought in that ecological balance with
themselves and a larger larger greater
ecology of things so that's what a lot
of people in the Western world are in
the modern world I mean obviously look
at parts of the East which the cities
are firing on all cylinders and being
even more destructive in some ways than
parts of the West it's not just a West
thing it's a modern modernity thing you
know that finding ways to reach maturity
in adulthood is is tough and that can
only be done through experience it can
only be done through harmony with the
way that you find processes and live
more authentically and it's not done
through sitting in your cubicle and the
nine-to-five you've talked about the
bottom line of the rat race a lot in
your material Alan and if everybody's
realizing that there's there's so much
more to life than that and so much of
what you spoke of in your metaphor of
the two brothers is just about yes this
polarization that we see just on such
full-spectrum firing on all cylinders
now with politics and everything and
that what rach speaks of is this
maturity through experience and
initiation into unity of not binary but
you know non-binary right just this this
unity of one realizing what we are is
more than we are all one which sounds
like a very movie metaphysical thing and
what do you what does that really mean
when we boil it down the oneness of
everybody is that we are all
collectively having the same experience
and we could think of much of what we're
doing is just you know this dream of
life and how do we learn from this
polarization as a teaching tool maybe
life is just to teach us about all these
things that we do well and that we have
to take away and when this mortal coil
wraps up be like what do you learn from
this crazy wild life of not to be in
fear but to just think of wow what a
ride what an amazing ride this life was
so the point of all this is just to say
that the show is one of our ways that
rack
I hopefully can do our ever-so-slight
part and highlighting some of these
larger overarching overarching
brushstrokes but then also showing to
people what some of these indigenous
ceremonies are like and some of these
initiatives you know what's the
importance of the journey the sacraments
the pilgrimages and the ceremonies which
specifically the second episode really
highlights as we go through this earth
air fire water process and episode
specific ceremonies and the importance
of them and why they're done in the
context with the medicine in ceremonies
with the drive with the village with the
unity of the whole community perfect
segue into this so mmm we've talked now
so much actually right prior to that I
just want to say there's another thing
that we've been talking about on the
program quite quite a bit recently and
it spoke to this idea of being able to
visualize the energetics especially
between like humans and one thing that's
very interesting is this idea of being
able to to have a of a biometric
measurement of a state of consciousness
so if if we were to take the state of
like a Dalai Lama or something and their
biometric state of consciousness and
catalogue that is deeply interconnected
or unconditional love the drops in the
ocean and then try and like analyze the
biometric state of like a like a
shrimping or Donald Trump or Jeff Bezos
or Mark Zuckerberg and you just really
just start like being just blatant like
there's 2,500 billionaires submit them
all into the biometric consciousness
analysis and see how many of them need
little tiny nudges towards these states
of interconnectedness and so we've been
talking about that quite a bit on the
program and then you know we're using
these words in this kind of another
great segue into what I wanted to
mention off of what you just said which
is that if you take these words of X
toss or these words of a yoga which we
have to remind people all the time means
Union in Sanskrit Union with the one and
you can take whatever path you want to
take right there's eight billion of us
that have eight billion unique
communions that are like snowflakes or
instruments being played in the symphony
that
commune with that that there are all of
these different modalities in terms of
communion in terms of in and so part of
what this question that I want to that I
want to ask is is that the modalities
are there's so many of them for
thousands of years this practice of
meditation for thousands of years this
practice of sacred plant medicines and
our interactions with them there's so
many from modalities so question being
in episode 1 and an episode 2 it seems
like an episode 2 there's so much of a
like a really deeper highlight with
these four elements to walk us through
the process of the communion that people
are having because maybe it is that the
more that we talk about our own unique
communions with the one as well as
sharing our stories sharing these
practices of indigenous cultures around
the world of the communions that we can
then excite more people to care about
their own processes of community hmm so
you know we're saying how we choose
these these episodes and number two
chose us it fell into our lap of a group
of modern Mexican spiritual seekers who
live in LA were also media makers who
had seen and liked episode one that
invited us to go down to Mexico this
March and that is the season when the
rich old people of Mexico who are one of
the the oldest tribes in Mesoamerica
that went you know conquered or
culturally sort of decimated by
modernity who live in the the remote
mountain ranges and they have a
relationship with what they call Hickory
and what we call in in the West peyote
which is you know in the cactus family
contains mescaline and other alkaloids
and is a profoundly visionary experience
but yet again that's just the outside
wrapper to describe it so the medicine
person of the witch hole is called a
Murakami usually a man it's usually
passed down through the lineage and
there can be multiple
there's dozens and dozens of Murakami
villages in the area they still live and
there's hundreds and hundreds of marrow
comets so this is a community where
shamanism is still vibrant and alive and
again isn't just about this one plant
it's about that they're part of that
maintenance and reciprocal energetic
exchange keeping the community healthy
and in well-being so we were invited
down in March because the which I'll go
on a pilgrimage you know which in the
judeo-christian ik terminology really a
pilgrim is a seeker it's a seeker that's
in search of knowledge or connection or
a spiritual outcome and it has a
religious connotation right it's not
just a holiday it's not just drug
tourism as Vice would probably call it
right this is an indigenous ceremony and
it's not just about the peak experience
so for me this was the big differences
from episode one in the sense that the
maraca made on Don Jose Ramirez who is a
very well respected chieftain and
murakami shaman in his community he's in
his mid-60s and he's been working at
this since he was about 10 again these
cultures which have an intergenerational
legacy of working with the medicines
don't see them as evil or bad or drugs
it's relationship it's like you're gonna
breathe air you're gonna you know like
get out there and swim you you have a
relationship with the elements and with
nature so Don Jose was legendary
he's there's been other documentaries
made about him but as a archetypal
representation of the murakami medicine
man what the big difference was with
this episode was really about the
pilgrimage and about the reefs a
creolization we had a little tribe of
men women and children there was
probably about 50 or 60 of us and we'll
travel on these little mini buses and
cars and we went from San Luis potosí
and Zacatecas the capital city where we
all met and we would just travel out and
we did not sleep right this is no this
is no no because here's the thing is
that is that we had a very short amount
of time
and the multiple Murakami's from their
villages in the mountains who travel
these hundreds of kilometers on the
pilgrimage go there both to re-enact the
original meeting and there's a lot of
cosmology here where they have
representations of the peyote as a
spirit as the blue deer and that
originally the original tribes person
had found and met and taken peyote and
that kept a continuity of the legends
and the mythology but a lot of the
journey was about well all of the
journey was essentially about tracing
the route of the sacred sites on the
road to where akuto and we're recruiter
is the Holy of Holies
it's like nature's desert Vatican for
them no structures per se but it's where
the peyote is and is indigenous to and
where it grows in quantities now we've
got to warn that peyote is an endangered
plant medicine and sacrament and vegetal
substance partially because of climate
change and of outside factors but also
partially because of Western
interference and that you know it takes
about seven or eight years for a p OD
pop or a bud to grow into full blossom
and it can take multiple peyote buds to
get a crescendo of the entheogenic
visionary experience so you know the
West is known about this for decades but
the the drain or the pressure put on the
ecology in the cultivation of peyote is
a big issue that we want to talk about
the documentary and it is the issue here
and in North America where it grows in
Texas and other regional states around
there as well grow anywhere else in the
world it's been transplanted but not in
its a desert bearing you know cactus
there's efforts underway to sort of with
multiple plants that are endangered
because because of both the Western
demographics drain on resources
ayahuasca is the same there's a whole
movement to repopulate ayahuasca same
with the bull photo from Episode one for
fair trade toad a peyote has been
endangered for decades and there's not
enough for even the Indians you know for
the Mesoamericans so
the whole tribe came with us all these
people men women and children and they
prayed right it's not just let's go to a
weekend ceremony where this visiting
shaman is doing his thing it's like
there was hardship there was sacrifice
there was ritual there was tradition
there was relentless ritual sacral
ization of what needed to be done at
each side and the reason for that is the
Maccabees believe that the earth is
alive and when I say alive obviously it
births certain life but it's
intelligently a lot it is the great
being or part of the even greater being
and that great being has a reciprocal
relationship with all its creatures
which must be maintained just like the
Murakami's maintain the health of the
well-being of their community so -
they're maintaining the well-being of
the earth community and how humans
interface with the other species in the
earth itself this is not a metaphor
I think terms of Aikido might have said
the earth is alive and we're in
relationship with it and it's not a
healthy one at the moment so some of the
sacred sites that we saw you know where
for instance that the holy Springs where
they believed when the great floods
resided that thousands of years ago when
life first re flourished surrounded by
fences in the backyard of suburban San
Luis Potosi and they've got cultural
issues about getting access to their
sacred sites because of capitalism
buying up the land and other associated
features that there was really this
ragtag poor in a sense pure people they
were on their annual pilgrimage to
gather as much peyote as they could to
take it back to the rest of the village
in their tribes in the mountains to do
them the entire year and on the way we
stopped at all these sites relentlessly
sacra lysing and giving thanks and
blessing with water and with prayers and
with feather and with live animal
sacrifice because blood is the great
carrier blood is you know the great
conductor of life of spirit so there are
ancient traditions that had to be
maintained and Don Jose Rama Reza's
dedication to the rituals was really
hard opening and to go on that
pilgrimage over multiple days to endure
to give it up to be present with it that
is what was needed to approach taking
the peyote with respects and permission
in the final legs it wasn't just you go
to this weekend ceremony there was this
pilgrimage there was his purification
and there was his sacrifice and we shy
away from sacrifice it's too hard it
hurts
let's put Nets up around our trampolines
let's put helmets on let's protect
ourselves from the wind and the Sun and
the earth and the element of danger
which makes you feel alive right it's
like we're mollycoddled in our society
and it's like there's no safety net out
there on the edge with shamanism and
that's how why you can encounter
something real within yourself that
you're connected to that is also outside
of yourself oh and what you speak to
Ellen with the elements you know like
we're obviously talked extensively about
commodifying the elements and how that's
completely unsustainable with you know
selling corporate water bottles or
buying up land and especially over
somebody's sacred site or burning the
Amazon over some indigenous tribes like
place that they've had for hundreds of
thousands if not millions of years that
stuff is not going to last but in terms
of the elements energetically I mean
visiting these sites for the earth the
air the water and the fire these have
deep you know principles within the
magic of practice right and so it's it's
important to realize that magically and
spiritually what you mentioned in your
question is so much people realize all
of these various modalities of
spirituality are turning people in word
and when you turn inward you realize you
start to have these chrysanthemum
blossoms about realizing these things
within you it's so much about your state
of mind and your way of being and your
the way that you harmonize with others
yourself your inner self your higher
self
and the community as a whole which is
the guy an ecosystem which the tribe
yes very wisely says is a living entity
a wiser creature so these elements are
really highlighted through this
pilgrimage which is always sacrificed
because think of in your life how many
times you've been you've done something
that's struggle and difficulty and how
much that's led to great reward right so
it's like there's some old alchemical
quote that says like the oldest forests
and the deepest the tallest mountains
and the deepest deserts as climbing a
mountain is obviously like an allegory
for this spiritual path so that's the
struggle and difficulty in it is it is
making this thing like as Rach said we
did it in about three days of shooting
which is very very tough it's a very
tight schedule and it was very that
alone is tough and then doing this
pilgrimage in a very beautiful landscape
where it could wear coot is amazing it's
like it is a desert but it's like a
cactus jungle where you think like
desert means you're going this like just
dead Rock moonscape but it was really
actually quite lush and beautiful and
the peyote is a beautiful yeah little
access doorway through this inner
experience it looks like a little
beautiful muffin and an innovating
entity it's a beautiful little almost
alien entity yeah and that's why like
we're wearing these wristbands that
shows some aspect it depends on people's
inner experiences how you are when you
have an experience of ever-so-slight
gnosis and gnosis is just a knowing that
something is the case my experience was
very visible visual and RAC and I are
wearing these wristbands which the tribe
makes as a way to through their own
creative art give a little bit of
insight as to what some people
oftentimes experience mmm but um it's
it's our struggle with the show is
always like how do we show these inner
experiences which to some extent can
never be done lense externally but my
goal as a documentarian and rack's goal
as you know my co collaborators to
always try and deliver the best product
possible in terms of the show in yes the
commerce of day to day modernity which
we do sell the episodes but also combine
beauty with wisdom you know combined
some of these wisdom aspects that we've
talked about there in this conversation
with what is beautiful show it in a
beautiful way because beauty has this
beautiful relationship with truth you
know if you go and look at a Rembrandt
painting you know there's some truth in
that thing
there was a manly P Hawk quote that once
said something to the extent of like all
unreal things are ugly and all true
things are beautiful and you know dr.
publicly just again just acknowledge the
beauty of your cinematography and
direction the ability to capture so when
you're in nature this is thing and you
know modern humanity live in cities over
50% of people in the world now live in
cities and you know they're not nature
right
it's like culture is a cargo cult that
is like blossom like a candida virus or
something within nature and it's
separated it drains all resources from
the periphery to the center of where and
it it stays in as little boxes and it
tries to control its relationship with
nature when we were out in we recruiter
which is the holy of holies lands it's
now said very beautiful in its desolate
aridness you start to pick up a sense
after days there of the shape of of
things of the fact that there are
energetic rhythms you know and like
you'll see the sunrise and the beauty
and you'll feel the wind and you see the
the birds and the animals wake with the
song realize oh the energy exchange of
the song and the light and the hate and
the day and it's like seeing the great
being wake up yes and then there are
these moments when you know there'll be
distance astounding synchronicities
where a cloud will part and Sun will
come through or you know a flock of
birds will all turn left all at once
even though they're like this group
entity that's one being and who's
leading and and there's these rhythms
within rhythms where I really start to
see the contours of the great being
right of what why they pray to nature
why they Ries acryl eyes why they
reconnect because you can't be separate
unless you choose and even then you're
not really separate you're just not
tuning in but there's there's an
energetic reciprocal relationship I mean
we haven't even mentioned you know the
sixth grade species extinction and the
planetary emergency that is hit the fan
everywhere right and so the thing is the
planet won't die
but things are hitting the fan the
carbon dioxide that methane released the
forest fires burning the bush fires the
flooding the extreme weather Queens
eating the coral bleaching everything is
dying off and it's it's like we're
ignoring it we're ignoring it because
we've ignored nature we just like where
do we get the refill from and it's like
you know it's like okay the living being
that we are and when we say embedded in
these words don't do a justice right
it's like we're in the mother we're in
this holy sacred creature which is the
womb of life and we're hiding away now
concrete little boxes right draining all
the things looking at Netflix and
creating a virtual world where we can be
more protected it's not gonna end well
so I just want to bring it back to this
idea what is shamanism why do we do what
we do what do we talk ument this why is
this important
right and I'm not saying you have to go
off and take peyote and if you do do it
with the indigenous people and their
permission that because there's not
enough to go around harvesting of the
mass and the whole you know but to have
an experience through whatever modality
whether that's breath work whether
that's reversing whether that's plant or
animal psychoactive medicines whether
that's Tantra lovemaking whatever tunes
you in to your deeper being reconnects
you to the web of life and then you can
give and receive and you can become a
whole human being because the modern
human is atrophied it is bastardized it
is like this zombie really you know
racing towards the apocalyptic cliff and
it's not good it's not healthy and
that's why the earth is in
transformation and upheaval it's purging
the human virus because the children
have lost their way and these indigenous
cultures who aren't the noble savages
we're not trying to lionize and gran
dies them into these pure beings they
have their own [ __ ] in their own
politics and their own egos but to a
degree from whatever sliver of a degree
they remember the spiritual connection
not just as a lifestyle but mediated
potentially through their medicine men
and women as the West is relearning they
can navigate the shitstorm of modern
culture
are you saying we can't buy rainforests
on amazon.com right it's it's true I
mean it's such a beautiful way to say it
that navigating how seeing what they do
well is definitely a teaching tool and
everything is a teaching tool
everything's a learning experience so in
word processes are a great way for you
to have the best insight as to what is
truth for you and for the larger
collective as a whole right and that's
what is so key I mean this well through
all that we've talked about in this
conversation much of which sounds very
interesting some of which sounds kind of
bleak but there's a lot of positive
things to be gained by people turning
inward and not ignoring things are not
becoming very egotistical but seeing
that in word processes are kind of the
forward escape the forward progress the
forward learning upward maze is a moment
as you have now documented the process
of communing with the one with nature is
a process of deep reciprocity
there's ritual throughout that is deeply
[Music]
oriented about communing with nature in
so many different variables when you
look at a a brief a brief landscape take
out the phone selfie aka a selfish take
on and then leave that in itself is
cancer compared to arriving and seeing
the depth that you were describing where
you can actually experience the sunrise
and the awakening of the conscious being
the plants the animals in that area
for that day and seeing when you look
for an extended period of time at a
landscape you no longer just see it you
feel it even beyond feeling it becoming
it and you also just you there's way
more nuance that has seen over time than
if you look at it for just a couple
seconds this process of going and
stopping over and over again along this
path towards towards the the harvesting
of the sacred plant medicine and then
the the process of of going on the these
the spiritual journeys there's something
that deeply reminds me we've talked
about this so many times miles rack of
glowing inward and this process of
knowing yourself and having these these
experiences can be so simple they do not
need such great complexities of needing
to go to a 10-day silent sittings or to
go to the the locations where you can
take on these plant medicines it can be
as simple as we've mentioned this on the
show so much that to leverage the breath
as the divine tool that it is that
communes you when the sip of water comes
and we take it in to realize the
divinity within that the bite of food
the divinity within that the powered by
the Sun which then gives you power all
of these tiny things that happen
throughout your day that you do on a
daily basis to have the deeper amounts
of gratitude in the deeper amounts of
communion through just those tiniest
micro pieces catalyze the small
butterfly effects when when you also
pause before you eat a meal with someone
and just pause it look at them in the
eyes and take the time to bless the fact
that you are sharing a meal together and
to bless that food before you take that
sip of water with someone say that it's
so beautiful that this water is
nourishing us right now and those tiny
little things can also catalyze that
deep inward journey that we need to
build to architect that social fabric
that enables Prosperity that is so
healing and regenerative goes that Allen
you just very eloquently I don't know if
you consciously did it or unconsciously
did it you just talked about four things
which are four alchemical elements that
we talked about that you what do you do
you bring them into your body right so
those are there's a little ham right
there that your body is the alchemical
vessel and we talk about these things in
terms of like what is the point of all
this it's yes it's this journey of
finding a beautiful balance in health
with body mind and spirit and then also
finding a way that you can essentially
use your mind in a way positively
realizing so much as mind base using
your heart in another beautiful way
because ultimate reality you don't know
until you can actually feel it and a lot
of these shamanic experiences allow you
to feel reality what is actually
not just five cents material reality
which is only part of the puzzle and
then how do you pursue your true will in
life like what are you doing with your
life and what are these
how are you integrating these
experiences into your own source code to
then live your life in the most
authentic way possible through your own
ventures and how you choose to spend
like a commodity your time right so
that's what this show is part of our way
of using our time in a way to help
disseminate the Internet information
just like you do with this show right
and so that kind of is a that's part of
our own process spiritually and now
chemically of how we better ourselves
through the process we're process
oriented in this journal
we're not goal oriented we're process
oriented do you have any thoughts on
that last probably it usually does
that's one of the backtrack a few you
helps keeping thoughts there so you know
the great bard Terence Mckenna
had some well there's so many quotes but
he has a little riff is his plan plant
planet right it's in the language right
that there's a plan you know
that's under way involving the plants as
part of the planet right and then we're
all part of it and it's it even being
said that you know the plants invented
the humans or assisted in the biospheric
sort of evolution of the plants to carry
the Seas to propagate the plants to
breathe out the carbon dioxide which
which they need in the reciprocal
relationship yeah I mean I think we're
scared to look at the the symbiosis of
nature because it would mean that all
Farquhar in something we're not the
Dominion conquers all area it's like
we're in a living organism and that's
totally changes the paradigm and Terence
also said that basically at times of you
know great societal unrest which happen
in the rise and fall of civilizations
like clockwork right because there are
larger rhythms of time and within that
it's like cultures rise and fall like in
this sort of like species petri dish
right there's this is thing which
happens as its dissemination there's his
growth phase and then there's a phase
where it's duster decay starts to die
and then there's another cycle and so at
times when the cycle goes the pendulum
swings backward we start
we start to contract and we start to
look back to the times when things made
sense right so at the moment we're
seeing that in the world is this return
of authoritarian father figure leaders
who are conservative and you know in
Shiller and withdrawing from the global
cooperative sort of web but it goes back
even further than that
it goes back beyond patriarchy
essentially to the utopian eden's we had
in pre civilization it goes back to what
Terrance called the archaic revival the
archaic meaning how did we survive for
potentially up to 1 million years in
different hominid forms how did we
flourish how we survived five great
species extinctions which modern science
says have plagued the world before and
we've had global warming's before
looking to those great species
extinctions naturally occurring global
warming's which raised the carbon
dioxide think of the fourth or the fifth
extinction we did that there's not
always meteorites or asteroids which do
it right
essentially there are rhythms within the
living guy an organism where we're in
and civilizations rise and fall and when
we go back looking for stability looking
for Center looking for meaning it always
involves nature because we remember
again the real story of what we're
embedded in what we're part of and now I
said it before it's not just at these
words I must feel sorry that they're not
enough to communicate these are maps but
it's about the feeling it's like I could
say to you the word I'm in love right
and it sounds nice and it might trigger
your you know responses energetically of
your own feelings of love and all the
sudden you start to feel you start to
sensitize you start to come back into
the somatic experience of the spiritual
being in a body in the temple as Niall
said in the vessel which is being
created by nature to hold its divine
spark right and modern humans and this
is my reef from ages ago I call it they
have species PTSD we you know we do
because we are not just blinkered we
have armoring we have this desensitized
nature where we don't go out into nature
we're scared of nature and we've been
pillaging it for hundreds of years
since the Industrial Revolution in the
the wave of the time cycle and now it's
coming back to a different thing and so
the reason why these experiences whether
they're psychedelics from a lab or you
know plant or animal based entheogen
psychoactives can help people at this
time of great planetary emergency it's
not because you see pretty pictures or
visions or that it's hallucinations or
escapism it's an escape hatch back to
reality right to the original state of
being which is feeling that there is no
separation between you and the air and
the sky and the Sun and the lake and the
fish and the animals that Lakota Indians
call this maitake arson you know all my
relations all these different cultures
around the world have a concept that
they feel not just think of how
everything is interrelated in the
Unified Field in the web of life and
we're starting to reget that through
modern science and quantum stuff and the
understandings of biology and in the way
talk threads together but we're not
feeling it yeah you know and so these
substances have the potential to open
your hearts not just your mind that's
why there's not about psychedelics
entheogens mean to awaken the divine
within right and I that they are
necessary and important and secreted by
the planet herself to mediate the
species consciousness and to bring us
back into right relationship with the
planet and so many other speakers have
said - it's like it's a growing body of
thought my last little riff I want to
say on this little bit of the subject is
Jesus yes there's a beautiful guy in the
UK up Sam Gandhi's a PhD he works with
the Beckley Institute that's doing a lot
of the legal scientific research with
psychedelics I've just done a DMT study
on what's happening the brain MRIs EEG
thinking is like neil lucid dreaming all
this other stuff his speciality is echo
Daleks is the idea of psychedelics or
indigency psychoactive substances as not
just modulators of consciousness but of
relationship a relationship with
ourselves with each other and
yeah and if you take an entheogenic
psychoactive substance in nature in the
right set and setting preferably with a
sitter or a guide you know someone's
looking after you you remember the
wonderment of all of creation or the
potential is there for you to remember
so at the moment there is this very
pronounced and a lot of momentum around
the medicalization of psychedelics which
I support there's also a lot of
commodification and capitalist interest
in the profit margins around the
commodification of psychedelics in
modern psychotherapy which I did not
necessarily support and there is very
little conversation around the spiritual
nature and potential of these substances
so all the attention or a lot of the
attention is going towards people with
anxiety stress and PTSD which is
probably like 70 to 80 percent of the
general populace in Western countries
because it's a battery farm that's
designed to drain all our energy until
we die right
anyway if you take these substances in
an environment they're not just for if
you have something wrong you don't have
to be sick to take these substances
although there is an element of
spiritual disconnection that even while
humans are probably not as connected in
the spiritual nature as as we could be
that if you do these things in nature
and Sam Gandhi's hypothesis and PhD is
all about reconnecting in a spiritual
sense like this he's a he's a I figured
the Japanese to him is like Shinto zoo
or something it's like forest bathing
where without a psychoactive you can go
into nature and just be and you are
getting fed the oxygen from the plants
and the trees the sunlight the wind the
air the insects as energetic reciprocal
exchanges happening all the time which
your DNA picks up on and starts to come
alive - and you breathe deeply the gift
of life and if you do that with a
psychoactive sacrament right it's not
recreational it's remembering the sacred
and if you do that in nature there's
been a study done on this potential of
these substance
to renew the sacred contract in the
sense to renew or release the armory to
make people whole again to remember the
sacred and I would love to see more of
an awareness around this potential I see
that the psychedelic community has
evolved from taking the substances
serving the substances there is a whole
movement of integrational list and
people that meet to share their
experiences and have support networks
for each other integrating afterwards go
out to the forest together when the
spring comes right I'm not suggesting
you do anything illegal but if you were
to do it on mass like a tribe like a
band of brothers and sisters in a
controlled setting setting in nature and
just be with it then that is the archaic
renewal right that is the potential you
don't have to be sick and traumatized on
PTSD in $6,000 for three MDMA sessions
with your therapist to go out in a
controlled environment nature and feel
the love of being alive again and in the
shamanic experience in a guided setting
setting with a facilitator or a medicine
person that is what they do they hold a
ceremony they recycle eyes and in that
peak experience of the entheogenic bliss
potentially there may be healing there
may be trauma release but if you don't
have that or the the opposite of trauma
is the connection it's held it's loved
and that that is what is needed by so
many people so I see the the shamanic
resurgence as this unification of old
and new eastern west and of heart and
mind you know of coming together into
this remembrance of who and what we
really are guided by the elders and
guided by the connection with the tribal
indigenous cultures guided by the
planetary intelligence which secretes
these substances which coincidentally
fit our neural structure and help us to
remember it's like we're meant to do
this
things are happening the way they are in
an intended way seems like a divine plan
yeah I think we have a lot of teaching
tools within nature I just was speaking
about the Sun and Moon and the balance
of the feminine and the masculine and
how these are obvious teaching tools to
man and nature shows us so much about
racket what's rack has just illustrated
you know it's such a teaching tool
nature and experiences in it are
endlessly priceless and especially when
you get older and you realize that you
much rather go out on a walk with your
dog rather than watching the you know
bread and circuses of the football match
or something it's like these experiences
with a specific sacrament whether or not
you like spirit you're in nature with
them or not or just kind of like another
leveling up of that experience right and
doing them in kind of specific ways in a
sacred context with the tribe rarely
helps gives you insights and they can be
very life-changing insights so these
life-changing processes of mind heart
connection I mean that's your that's
your empowerment as an individual
they're full spectrum human full
spectrum human but you know that's what
the show tries to highlight so we
encourage folks to take a take a look at
it and see that for us this show is a
spiritual process because like all
spirituality it's it's essentially water
on stone so it's a slow process but
whatever we output aims to always be of
high quality right so spirituality is
your life and it's your slow real
internal life it's your inner life your
real life and this show is a little bit
of a glimpse into what's happened to us
through our lives and our processes and
it happens in a very natural way just
like nature grows slowly this show grow
slowly and it's very life changing for
us and the process of making it so you
know thanks for allowing us to talk
about it in that
we always appreciate that we appreciate
your interest and resonance and I know
it it's totally on your wavelength oh
yeah yeah you you two are definitely
some of my favorites and I I must also
say that probably in the last couple of
months that mmm most recently this idea
that the most upstream or route issue
that we face is the remembrance of the
interconnectedness the remembrance of
the one and we asked that question quite
a bit now on on the show is what is the
most upstream issue that we face and I'm
totally agree with you yeah III think we
can solve any problem with our ingenuity
and the technology if we understand what
the problem really is and you know
taking a small sliver or doing
geoengineering and you know sucking the
thing out of here and it's it's all
interconnected
and until you understand the connection
and in a sense the the curation of all
the species and the intelligence behind
that you know it's like the the bees
spreading the the the pollen and the
making the honey and pollinating the
flowers and this interspecies symbiosis
and cooperation that happens you can
[ __ ] it up but if we remember the sacred
if we remember our connection to the
sacred I realize we're not really in
control right it's it's the egoic
separation of not feeling that
connection it's like my shorthand is
it's like essentially we're like
sailboats when you put the sail up and
the wind carries you right it's like
when we try to do things we're trying to
cut through the water we're trying to do
this stuff and it's coming from this
thing which thinks it's in control but
when you let yourself be carried by the
force of the intelligent loving nature
of reality and you still have to
navigate and do things but you're guided
you're supported you're you're you're
part of something bigger right and there
may be hardships but that's part of the
path that's part of the sculpting right
things are happening for you not to you
and if we remember that then the times
that are coming we can navigate from the
heart and we can transform I'm not
saying we're going to survive but we can
transform and we can understand there's
a greater ecology there's a greater
meaning we come from somewhere we go
from somewhere don't attach to what's
here now it's always changing right
yeah the dream of life the beautiful
dream of life that shows us so much
through our process here right
everything is a teaching tool on a
learning tool so that's that's something
to never forget and you know to take it
away on yeah positive know what I mean I
think that so much of this is just about
greater processes which again we're
being shown as as we're being forced to
do things in natural ways that's what
I'll say and it's not it's scary in the
mean time but it ultimately leads to
better things there's no you don't
improve unless you struggle you know
your growth and life is through your
struggle and your hardships so that's
what we're being shown we need to do
both individually and culturally and
societally it's not the buddies we go to
you experienced yeah you had oh you guys
did while you were yes buddy through
each episode we tend to oh it's
different for me because RAC is an
experiential journalist part of the
process for both episodes is actually
you know taking the sacrament and being
on camera and I recognize the director
of the show you know I'm here you know
helping him off camera actually filming
it but then yes when we have spare down
time after we've essentially wrapped up
our responsibilities shooting I have had
the experiences and so both both
episodes I've taken the sacraments and
it's it's it's been very synchronistic
it's just like we say you are supported
through your processes if you find your
will in life and follow it it's amazing
how much things up and tell you it
doesn't mean it's not struggle it's
always struggle life is life is
difficult you know the spiritual path is
really tough most people don't want to
do it and so to be willing to open
yourself up to some of these experiences
my peyote experience was beautiful and
life-changing and very gentle and
wonderful and it's very much like an
analog to ayahuasca
which is apparently very feminine it's
very much a masculine guy in energy of
the larger ecosystem and you know you're
melting into the into the larger ecology
of things brings in that unity and that
oneness and that esoteric inward
empowerment it's empowering it's very
empowering and it's very educationally
uplifting so let me set the scene a bit
so after three days of pilgrimage to
weary ku to the holy of holy lands and
by the way I'd really like to emphasize
as well we're Acuto is endangered again
by capitalism again by this egoic
separation from understanding the
sacredness of the web of life by this
Canadian mining company which is like
horror of Horrors the most sacred land
for thousands of years of these people
that travel to take the peyote and take
it back to their communities it's
endangered already and it only grows in
certain geographic regions they're
mining and the main agreements with the
government etc etc and they're like well
we'll just go under the ground we won't
go above the ground and the whole you
know interrelated being and the it
pollutes and so the the the which holes
are fighting for the survival of their
culture of their communities of their
way of being because they don't just
take this substance once in a peak
experience they use it to mediate their
energy all through the year that's why
they have to have huge amounts of peyote
and one of the drain on the resources so
they take it back to the men women and
short men women and children do this
ceremony so you know it's it's it's
something which is culturally sanctioned
and much is permissible but necessary
for their indigenous way of life it
helps them connect individually
energetically and so we get to wear a
cooter and we're doing the filming and
it's you know late at night and the
maracas made on Jose they play these
violins which is so beautiful and
haunting and you know
you're like scratching and annoying at
the same time but beautiful it
highlighted in the episode yeah and and
it's again it's not random music it's a
certain vibrational frequency within
which great spirit speaks through and
energetically their vibration is healing
and cleansing and so during the day
there has been the hunt for the peyote
and there's prayers and rituals about
how to approach that and then we go off
and there's like tumbleweeds and the
desert is really full around where Okuda
with all the tumbleweeds and bushes and
it's hard to look and find anything and
so then they go on the hunt and they
find the peyote and you know they they
dig it up and and they start putting
them in bags and they're praying and
it's all very sacralized and done in a
certain way with respects and they bring
back these huge bags like 6 foot bags
you know men women and children like
heaps and heaps of bags of peyote and
they they're preparing them and getting
them ready for the ceremony at night and
then you know we take them together the
men the women and the children
little bits little ones and for me I
kept saying it was like a communal
prayer it was like one of the only times
you might go to a church in a building
structure in the judeo-christian Ex sort
of architecture but here in nature
you've got the incredible saturated
starry sky beaming down to you and
shooting stars and you've got the
freezing coldness and the feeling of
being alive you've got the fire which
they've lit and we've gone through days
of pilgrimage at the sacred water sites
blessing the water that gives life
blessing the land you know the open air
and the fire and the fire we've done
limb Peters and healings and cleansing
--zz and making these little knots of
their prayers to get rid of any sins
especially around sexual energy or any
misconduct to clean yourself to be ready
enough to receive and interact with the
vibrational spirit of peyote you don't
just eat it right you have to approach
it in a sacred way and we had the full
permission with all of Don Jose in the
Murakami's and the tribe to do so and so
then we ingest the medicine with great
reverence and gratitude and for me and I
I wasn't asked to comment more as well
because he is his great ability we
noticed nervous
one coming from Hollywood and special
effects and the audiovisual side of
things with technicians to describe the
interior visionary escapes with this
language which makes it digestible and
understandable so you know for me I only
had I must say it was like third day no
sleep out in the middle of nowhere
trying to hold it together this was a
the most demanding shoot I've ever done
in my life and I did I just took one
medium sized poj and I laid with the you
know around the fire and think and
wanted to tune into the experience and
again you know sometimes this happens to
me with ayahuasca as well it's not
necessarily visionary on that but it is
hard opening yeah and that bit where
there are no barriers there's no
armoring there's no separation my heart
is open and feeling and connecting to
the men women and children in the song
and I felt like it was a communal prayer
that we were singing what we were
feeling and what we were feeling was
connection to the mother and the planet
and each person was like a note in the
song yeah right and when you're feeling
it you're riding the rhythms and the
waves and it's real and you're getting
it because you're your aperture and your
bandwidth expands and you're not
thinking it you're receiving the signal
and so it was like this incredibly
sacred beautiful communal prayer that we
did as a community for ourselves for the
planet for Pachamama and for Great
Spirit and it was it was just a real
sacra lysing game changer for me in the
way I actually see shamanism beyond just
even the plant medicines in the
community in the relationships in the
sacrifice and in the spirituality well
with what you just said and the elements
you know giving that to you you're not
gonna want to commodify very much are
you then I compared to what our culture
doesn't to just get you know a little
controversial and funny about that I was
recently in Alabama at a wedding at a
megachurch little did I know of be at a
megachurch and I'm at this place
thinking this is just a completely
desperate relized place this is a very
hierarchical political patriarchal you
very political and like something that
has had essentially been D Spiritualized
because it's just a big money-making
machine versus being in somewhere like
where a CUDA through this indigenous
tribal experience of a true shamanic
spiritual experience that unions you
with nature's greatest ecology right so
you're taking in the sacrament that then
gives you an insight as to expansion of
what we're Kuta Mexico looks like from
the five senses you know you can see it
you can feel it you can touched it but
then the peyote experience is kind of
uploading you to the larger ecology of
it which has a completely different
fabric to it and my experience was not
only as hard opening were you melt into
the all of it you see the where I could
a jungle in this kind of very hyper
accentuated you know Truong landscape of
this little these little puppet figures
of the the cactuses come alive and are
shimmering and moving and giving
insights and each branch of them is a
spirit that's melting on to you and
giving you this kind of fractal
holography of a bleed through of
information and data right and all this
stuff is coming from nature so again
when you have these wonderful heart
opening mind expanding consciousness
expanding experiences through a true
Eucharist not just some cold cup that
has some apparently exoteric have truth
of a body of maybe what was once a
corporeal being you're actually seeing a
real direct connection with nature's
spiritual teachings nature is the
spiritual teacher who happens to be just
distributing this through a mesh wit
network of yes plants and animals and
other ways that you can do it through
pranayama breathing meditation other
ways that you can access it of course
what's so beautiful about shamanism is
the is how fast things can be
experienced in how life-changing things
can be in one night that's a beautiful
thing and that makes you less
controllable less on puppet strings more
empowered which is kind of terrifying to
untruth ways of doing things right so as
we move from truth to untruth that's
something that I highlight through an
experience that is just so cherishing
and all my traumatic experiences that
have come through this primary primarily
through the show in other ways that I
think we all feel this way you take with
them and you cherish them forever and
very life-changing and you use them in
your larger spiritual journey as
stepping stones along the way to better
your life yeah you can come with us next
episode oh yeah be fun to have you ma'am
you know we'd always a lot yes I would
adore that and just like this just like
miss Wow yeah just like the show you
know we would do these we would do these
whether or not we were documenting them
or not so I'd like to have this
conversation with you whether or not
it's being recorded
you know same with the show it's like we
do it anyway and it's nice because it
obviously like I mentioned the beginning
it utilizes our skill set and we do make
something that is a nice piece of our
portfolio but it's it's the experience
of it it's the process of doing it that
is the journey you know life's about the
journey and one last thing I'd like to
say is well that global shamanic
resurgence phrase you know resurgence
was chosen specifically because it's not
new right it's come before yeah but
there is this momentum now in what we
call the West or the modern world to
remember the sacred connection with
nature and to remember the intelligence
and the love and the what it's all about
and what we're in and previous cultures
have had this you know we talked a
little bit at the start about indigenous
tribal cultures and poor and all this
stuff it's like that's what we've done
to them right you know previous cultures
on the earth have been shown many
cultures which used indigents there's
the the city of Shaheen which was a in
South America which was a shamanic
culture which used potentially DMT
schnapps and San Pedro cactus and
probably ayahuasca and there's every
culture like great grand civilizations
you know all through South America I
listen to some podcasts recently is like
in the 1500s when some of the first
Spanish explorers went through the
reported Cities of Gold up and down the
Amazon and they found out we with thumb
lead our with the new laser technology
to see through the jungles they found
like you know 700 cities or the remnants
and they say though they were up like
17,000 people each so there were being
grand civilizations that have existed
that have existed in and with nature and
even in the city schematic with an
entheogenic component
labels them to connect to nature and
they we don't have to necessarily give
up anything except our expectations
right we don't have to give up like
going back to the jungles or going back
to nature and becoming cavemen no one's
saying that but there's a potential
through the healing of the mediation of
plant medicines and the shamanic
resurgence to remember who and what we
really are to remember the connection to
the planet and to take an organic
holistic life-affirming way to approach
the world and I'm seeing this a lot of
the new paradigm stuff all the you know
renewable technologies the solo the wind
you know all the ways that we can
capture the energy that's already there
to fuel our civilization in healthy
clean you know zero emission ways and we
can build a galactic civilization Alan
again as these ones used to have and and
I think that this this global shamanic
resurgence thing it's not it's it's
nothing small it's a great endeavor but
it's something which is being catalyzed
by larger forces and it's about that
unification so imagine 100 years from
now we're all living in a jungle that
covers the planet we're all living in in
in um abundance and we're all living in
love and community with a technology
that's embedded into the ecology and as
part of the ecology and you know it
survived the transformation of the sixth
grade species extinction and becomes
something new that it was always within
it to be that goes through those cycles
of time and has come out the other side
so that that's why I believe the
resurgence is nothing new but it has an
energetic impetuous and catalyzation to
it which is really necessary at this
time in in species evolution yeah
speaking of evolution and D evolution it
seems like you know larger energetic and
galactic forces fortunate forcing us to
go through spiritual processes may be
leading us to ways of living more
authentically through consciousness
expansion right and we see aspects of
society which sometimes feels like most
people seem to be D evolving and maybe
those they will eventually
you know recede into the Forgotten
shadows of time and through cycles of
time we see civilizations rise and fall
that are much more conscious societies
right and we look at things from the
past that obviously had technologies
that we don't have now such as great
relics that were built in very amazing
magical ways and it shows societies that
were much more expanded in their ways of
living and being and acting and how they
found harmony within themselves and
their larger ecology and connectedness
with everything so that those like it's
something like you know the pyramids as
proof that society has been around the
blocks for a long time and we've done
things in very interesting ways and have
you had Graham Hancock on the show
because you really should oh my god
Weezy's amazing we make civilization
there's a lot of wonder if this is
actually actually one of the things that
when you mentioned it it's a it's come
up a lot on the program now is that this
species amnesia we have we think that
all of the existing wisdom that we have
from the last 500 years post
enlightenment and Industrial Revolution
today is 0.1 percent of all history this
99.9% has a lot that can teach us and
one of the great problems of our time is
that we can't actually do the
archaeology fast enough as the artifacts
are disintegrating so we need to create
a massive global task force on
archaeology in specific places
especially the Fertile Crescent that
Amazon all of these coastal cliff
regions as well around the planet to
uncover I mean there's if you follow
archaeology as one of your news trends
instead of the
patience instead of that nastiness of
the of the fighting of the two polarized
sides
that stuff's killing you but if you
follow archeology as one of your new
sources the amount of discoveries that
are happening every day paradigms being
rewritten we've written as as we go and
so that's one of the most important
things is when you you know when you
look up at the cosmos the same thing is
happening where we are not mapping
continuously our cosmos and therefore
we're not doing the cosmic archaeology
where if we go through supernovas in
different places through the cosmos we
are not actually able to capture that
moment and log it and understand it
happening in that area so it's very
similar with our species as well of
discovering these moments of our ammm
Niva but this entire conversation I
think as well as these other most
profound guests and conversations that
we have on the program all point to the
interconnectedness they all point to
non-separation they all point to the one
and they all point to that with these
wisdoms that come from this 99.9% of
time pre-enlightenment Industrial
Revolution where by understanding those
wisdoms that we can architect a more
processes isn't it ironic they call it
the Enlightenment I mean having had
enlightenment experiences I'm like you
know the mechanistic reductionist is
success of rising civilization up out of
the poverty and all the things to a
certain degree but that's not
enlightenment you know that's
mechanistic success but I think
enlightenment is really coming it's
still coming it comes and it goes
hopefully it's coming back this thing is
sick
this is the most beautiful I've never
ever felt anything more beautiful than
what we are all experiencing Oh grace
it's it's really yeah with us very
Pacific are you guys both so much and I
mean this reality this um this creation
is just and so that is uh it's a miracle
yeah it's a gift that's why they call it
the present right but it is it's like we
get desensitized we wake up we here's
the thing we go to work you know and
I've seen you I've seen you grow over
the course of many episodes and thank
you for having us back and I see you on
the Facebook feeds and and your um your
language and your perception and what
you choose to give attention to has a
depth to it that it didn't say two years
ago and I personally in a show and so
you know before we started we lit a
little drop in a little breathing
exercise and as you said it's like
savoring each moment the awareness of
awareness is what we're really
cultivating over many lifetimes and if
we can become aware enough to not take
it personally to not attached and I have
a version or grasping to be the Inge
that is great then I think we've got it
and the Enlightenment will come yeah Wow
powerful adore you both thank you thank
you thank you thank you thank you
okay so again I love you guys coming
please show these one more time they
these a beta artwork say they do
let's do racks first they do little
figures but they also make the arm bands
so here's the thing each bead is
individually placed into the UM band in
this instance and theoretically each
bead what they're doing is a meditation
in a prayer so this represents some of
the energy signature patterns that you
can see for instance on my pedis and
meditate
a prayer yeah because the process of
doing it is like a meditation but it's
bringing them into mindfulness yeah and
it's like a prayer and it's anchoring on
the outside for others to see what they
see on the inside with their sacrament
of the peyote and it's another beautiful
example of somebody making something
cottage industry style from a creative
standpoint right it's like you're not
making this by some massive centralized
hierarchical top-down structure making
it from a like a little woman village
who makes beautiful art so so much of
reality and ways of getting back to
authentic authenticity are from the
bottom up you know from grassroots right
so beautiful so I know you're asking
that the show will be add in the spring
episode 2 episode 2 spring 2020 again
watch episode 1 of Sean's of the Global
Village the link is in the bio below if
you haven't seen it yet go watch it we
are so grateful that you tuned in to
this conversation thank you very much
everyone
greatly appreciate you have more
conversations with your friends families
co-workers people online about the
subjects that Niles and I've talked
about in this episode with us please
please please drop into those states of
interconnectedness of love drop in more
together into the one and catalyze that
there are even the most simple things
like the breath and the water and the
the most simple ones also support the
work that now sanrak do you can find the
links below to support them and the work
as well again it's very important to
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the spiritual leaders and your
communities and around the world that
you believe and support them support
them financially even with the small cup
of coffee or meal per month helps them
if around the world we did that for the
subscribers that tune into content we
could catalyze the awakening faster so
do support them financially as well
support the ones also in your
communities you'll find our links below
to our show as well paypal patreon
cryptocurrency all those links are below
and go and build that future that our
hearts all know is possible
we love you very much thank you for
tuning in we'll see you soon